un procès qui est très important
permettre de fixer les limites de la
critique que nous pouvons faire n'ont
pas alerté mais aux médias français qui
dépendent du csa est ce que on peut nier
renier la qualité de journaliste
aux personnes qui travaillent pour un
organe de presse qui est contrôlé par le
csa c'est la question qu'on pose il a
toujours été établi que ce n'était pas
possible que vous ne pouvez pas dire
d'un journaliste qui travaille par
exemple pour france télévisions ou
canal+ kim n'est pas journaliste que
c'est des âmes que c'est un
désinformateurs et qu'ils oeuvrent pour
qui fait de la propagande si vous le
dites vous êtes sanctionné la question
qui se pose aujourd'hui c'est est ce
qu'on peut lire d'ayrté et le tribunal
va
prononcer sa décision le 3 décembre en
clair la question qui se pose est ce qu
a demandé rtc parfaitement logique c'est
une application
juge afin habituel de la jurisprudence
là on va permettre de savoir puisque
certains ont des doutes assez légitime
de savoir si il ya deux poids deux
mesures' à une justice qui est
différente suivant que vous êtes rt ou
que vous êtes canal+ ou france
télévisions ou f là ça va être
intéressant d'autant que je rappelle une
fois de plus que le csa n'a jamais
condamné ou reprochés aux mis en demeure
rt d'avoir diffusé de fausses
informations
au contraire il le surveille et le
président du csa ne cesse de le dire
avec une attention toute particulière et
il veille à ce que la moindre le moindre
écart soit très sévèrement sanctionné il
n'y a jamais eu de sanction en ce qui
concerne l'information elle traitement
d'informations le fait que c'était
équilibré et donc il n'y a aucune raison
que le tribunal n'entre pas en voie de
condamnation